[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne gellineck guten Abend im
letzten Jahr hat die Gesellschaft für
deutsche Sprache den Begriff Zeitenwende
zum Wort des Jahres gekürt und damit
irgendwie auch den Kanzler geadelt der
den Ausdruck mit seiner bundestagsrede
erst so richtig populär gemacht hat
dieses Jahr ist das Wort des Jahres
genau krisenmodus der Begriff beschreibt
die Weltlage aber auch den Zustand des
Kanzlers seiner Regierung und seiner
Partei die SPD hat sich in Berlin zum
Parteitag versammelt ohne Haushalt aber
mit dem festen Willen zur
sozialdemokratischen
Selbstvergewisserung morgen redet der
Kanzler heute aber war der Tag der
Parteivorsitzenden die kräftig
loslederten gegen die Opposition Britta
spiermann berichtet aus
Berlin der Parteitag beginnt mit viel
Applaus für Olaf Scholz wärmend für den
Kanzler dessen Beliebtheitswerte laut
Umfragen im Keller sind der seit Wochen
keine Antworten gibt auf das
haushaltsdisaster doch hier unter den
seinen liegt Rebellion so gar nicht in
der Luft es ist eine
herausforderit bin froh wir alle sind
froh das konnest so eben am Applaus
spüren dass Du unser Bundeskanzler bist
der Ton auf dem SPD Parteitag ist
gesetzt Krise ja aber keine oder kaum
Kritik am führungszel des Kanzlers dass
die Zeiten düster sind das verschweig
lar klingball nicht der
coparteivorsitzende spricht vom Aufstieg
der AFD von der Spaltung der
Gesellschaft die Schuldenbremse sei ein
wohlstandsrisiko und immer wieder der
Name von Oppositionsführer Friedrich
Merz dessen Politik vor allem eins sei
unanständig Friedrich von gestern wird
niemals die Zukunft unseres Landes sein
die Zukunft dieses Landes ist ein Staat
der investiert ein Staat der Sicherheit
gibt und ein Staat der seine Bürgerin
und Bürgers schützt CDU und CSU hetzen
im Chor mit der AFD gegen die Ampel mit
dieser März CDU haben wir wahrhaftig die
populistischste Opposition aller Zeiten
der Funke spring er seltenüber trotzdem
klingen Beil und esken werden als
Vorsitzende wiedergewählt das alte neue
Doppel nichts anderes stand auf dem
parteitagsplan auch in der Ampel werde
man beim Haushalt zueinander finden bei
so viel Harmonie in der Parteispitze
droht die Realität aus dem Blick zu
geraten die nach Berlin angereiste Basis
nennt Tabus und wünsche ich würde mir
wünschen dass Olaf mal wieder den den
Kampfgeist rausholt der in ihm steckt
und den wir auch in der Bundestagswahl
und wahk amp bei ihm gesehen haben weil
der ist da aber das muss jetzt auch mal
die Menschen da draußen erreichen meine
Erwartungshaltung ist dass wir klare
Zeichen setzen was wir wollen als
Sozialdemokratie z.B keine Kürzung im
Sozialbereich z.B einen höheren
Mindestlohn und diese Zeichen müssen
jetzt raus auch an die
Koalitionspartner der Koalitionspartner
FDP wird kaum auf diese Zeichen warten
fordert der SPD Parteitag doch auch die
Reform der Schuldenbremse und eine
Abgabe für Reiche ampelkrise Neuwahlen
diese Worte scheint es nicht zu geben
wir wollen diesen Koalitionsvertrag
umsetzen wir wollen das Maximum
rausholen und alle Akteurin und Akteure
von parteifaktion und Regierung stehen
dafür ein Olaf Scholz lächelt viel am
ersten Tag des Parteitages seine SPD
gewährte ihm heute ein Heimspiel im
Tabellenkeller morgen wird Scholz seine
Rede halten bleibt er dabei keine
Antworten zu geben auf die
Haushaltskrise dürfte es wohl auch hier
ungemütlicher werden für den lächer
sch und aus Berlin ist uns jetzt die
frisch wiedergewählte Parteivorsitzende
der SPD Saskia esken zugeschaltet guten
Abend guten Abend Frau Gin Frau esken
der Parteitag hat Olaf wie er in der SPD
ja so schön heißt heute mit freundlichem
Applaus begrüßt wofür
eigentlich mit sehr freundlichem Applaus
weil Ola Scholz unser Bundeskanzler ist
und im übrigen auch Teil natürlich
unserer Partei mittendrin und dazuehört
und deswegen heute den Tag auch hier
verbracht hat normalerweise würde man ja
erwarten er hat seine Rede morgen na ja
da kommt er morgen nein Olaf Scholz ist
natürlich dabei wenn die SPD ihren
Parteitag eröffnet wenn Sie Ihre
parteivorsitzen neu wählt und das ist
gut und richtig so aber draußen im Land
sind die Werte für Olaf Scholz ja
schlecht wie nie zwei Drittel der
Menschen finden dass er dem Amt nicht
gewachsen ist und die Partei stürzt
bundesweit auf 14% ab was ist aus ihrer
Sicht der Grund
dafür wissen Sie wir haben jetzt
wirklich vier Jahre voller Krisen hinter
uns wir haben die coronapandemie noch
nicht überwunden gehabt da kam der Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine und wir wir
haben wirklich schwere Belastungen
gemeinsam zu zu stemmen gehabt nicht nur
die Regierung sondern vor allem die
Bevölkerung die Unternehmen und dass da
insgesamt die Stimmung auch sehr
verunsichert ist und natürlich jetzt
auch durch den Haushaltsstreit noch mal
vertieft verunsichert wird kann ich
absolut nachvollziehen deswegen ist es
ja auch so wichtig dass die SPD jetzt
auf ihrem Parteitag auch eine Richtung
vorgibt Orientierung gibt und deutlich
macht wir sind handlungsfähig wir haben
Konzepte wir wollen die Zukunft gut
gestalten damit es den Menschen besser
geht also keine Defizite beim Kanzler
das sieht der Parteitag
nicht wir haben gemeinsam ja diese
Arbeit auch in der Regierung entwickelt
Partei und Fraktion sind dort immer
wieder sehr stark eingebunden jeder
Koalitionsausschuss ist ja auch mit uns
besetzt äh wir entwickeln dort die
Arbeit gemeinsam wir haben den
Koalitionsvertrag gemeinsam
voran gebracht und insofern ist es eine
Arbeit die wir auch gemeinsam
verantworten und jetzt auch gemeinsam
weiterentwickeln das Haushaltsloch sie
haben es angesprochen ist weiter
ungestoppft und die Sparvorschläge die
wir heute auf ihrem Parteitag gehört
haben wirken ja so ein bisschen wie aus
der sozimottenkiste krisenabgabe für
Reiche Schuldenbremse lockern
Mindestlohn erhöhen alles Projekte die
sie ja von denen sie ja e wissen dass
sie in dieser Koalition mit der FDP
überhaupt nicht durchzusetzen sind wo
bleibt eigentlich der Realitätssinn der
guten alten
SPD na ja sagen wir mal so
Sozialkürzungen wie sie von anderer
Seite vorgeschlagen werden sind ja auch
relativ klar mit der SPD nicht zu machen
insofern kann man schon auch deutlich
machen wir hätten andere Konzepte wenn
es um Einnahmeverbesserungen geht ähm
oder eben auch Sparvorschläge
tatsächlich wenn Sie den Mindestlohn
dort mit nennen ein höherer Mindestlohn
würden natürlich zu geringeren
Sozialausgaben führen weil die Leute
eben auf eigenen Beinen stehen können
und das ist auch ihr Wunsch wer arbeitet
natürlich auch er zu mehr Ausgaben
führen
ne der höhere Mindestlohn führt zu mehr
Ausgaben bei den Unternehmen aber nicht
beim Staat aber es gibt ja eine Studie
des Bundesarbeitsministeriums das raus
die rausgefunden hat dass zu viele
Sozialleistungen in Deutschland Arbeit
unattraktiv machen und auch
Arbeitsaufnahme behindern da wird das
Bürger eld immer genannt würden Sie denn
mitgehen bei dem Vorschlag das
Bürgergeld im nächsten Jahr zu
kürzen nein auf keinen Fall und den das
Bürgergeld ist von der Koalition
übrigens auch mit den Stimmen der Union
beschlossen worden wir haben Harz 4
überwunden haben das Bürgergeld
eingeführt und wir haben dort auch klar
gemacht dass wir schneller also nicht
nach eineinhalb Jahren sondern schon
nach einem halben Jahr auf die jeweils
aktuellen inflationsswerte reagieren
wollen das ist trotzdem immer
nachlaufend und wir hatten einfach im
Lauf des Jahres noch eine hohe Inflation
und deswegen ist richtig dass das
Bürgergeld jetzt erhöht wird damit eben
die immer noch sehr hohen Preise bei den
Lebensmitteln bei den insgesamt den
Gütern des täglichen Bedarfs dass die
auch gestimmt werden können von den
Menschen da ist ja wirklich nicht viel
Geld vorhanden und ausgerechnet jetzt
bei den Ärmsten sparen zu wollen um die
um die Krise zu bewältigen das halte ich
wirklich für schäbig
und finanziert werden soll das Ganze
indem die SPD auch im nächsten Jahr eine
Notlage erklären will und damit die
Schuldenbremse aussetzt warum äh glauben
Sie dass das verfassungskonform
wäre na ja das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil
hat uns ja sehr deutlich gesagt was
bisher gängige haushaltspraxis war
nämlich die Notsituation einmal zu
erklären und dann die
Kreditermächtigungen aus diesem Jahr in
Folgejahren zu verwenden ist ja die
Ampel nicht die erste Regierung die das
so hält das ist in Landesregierungen so
gemacht worden und auch in anderen
Bundesregierungen zuvor diese
Notsituation ist ja genauso Teil der der
Verfassung wie die Schuldenbremse selbst
und das
verfassungsgerichturteil hat eben gesagt
nee es gibt schon Krisen die über
mehrere Jahre hinweggehen aber dann
müsst ihr die Notsituation jedes Jahr
neu erklären und ich finde schon sehr
klar dass wir inmitten einer Krise
stecken und dass wir nicht erwarten
können dass die in 2024 sofort vorbei
sein wird denn der Krieg dauert an die
Ampel regiert heute auf den Tag genau 2
Jahre und die Opposition in Person des
CDU Generalsekretärs hat vorgeschlagen
dass der Kanzler doch die
Vertrauensfrage im Parlament stellen
solle wie nervös macht sie dieser
Vorschlag das macht mich in keinerweise
nervös weil der Bundeskanzler die das
Vertrauen seiner Koalition genießt und
unser Vertrauen sowieso wir werden
dieses dieses Thema jetzt in der
Koalition lösen in den nächsten Tagen
wird dann eine Lösung erarbeitet werden
da bin ich sehr zuversichtlich und dann
werden wir weiter daran arbeiten dass
das Land gut durch die Krisen kommt das
ist aber auch sich in die Zukunft
orientiert dass wir investieren können
in die Infrastruktur in unserem Land in
Industriearbeitsplätze und vieles mehr
sagt sask esken SPD Parteivorsitzende
herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch ich danke
Ihnen und das Interview haben wir vor
genau einer Stunde
aufgezeichnet das Loch im deutschen
Haushalt schlägt Wellen bis nach Brüssel
gestern und heute trafen sich dort die
EU Finanzminister und streiften auch das
Thema des europäischen Haushalts der
Rahmen für die EU gemein augaben wird
jeweils für 7 Jahre festgelegt jetzt ist
ungefähr Halbzeit und Überraschung es
fehlt Geld die EU-Kommission verlangt
einen Nachschlag von 66 Milliarden Euro
von den
EU-Mitgliedstaaten darunter ein 50
Milliarden Hilfspaket für die Ukraine
schon vor der deutschen Haushaltskrise
hatten Kanzler und Finanzminister die
Budget Aufstockung kritisch gesehen
jetzt wollen sie erst recht sparen die
Ukraine aber braucht das Geld drend z.B
für den Wiederaufbau Julia rech und Ulf
Röller
berichten ab und zu kehrt olessia zu
ihrem Haus zurück und denkt an ihr altes
Heiles Leben gleich zu Beginn des
Krieges zerstörten es russische
Bomben das hier war unsere Küche wir
haben uns hier alle versammelt und
gefeiert dort oben hat mein Sohn
gewohnt ohne Geld aus Europa wird sie
ihr Haus nicht wier aufbauen können wie
viele andere in irpin knapp 30 km
entfernt von Kiev die Stadt ist zu fast
70% zerstört jetzt hören sie vom
Haushaltsstreit in der EU vom Zweifel
der ihnen Angst
macht wir warten auf die Gelder wir
hoffen wirklich dass sie kommen wir
brauchen dringend Hilfe in Brüssel gibt
es einen Haushaltsstreit der auch die
Hilfsgelder für die Ukraine betrifft die
Kommission will den EU um 66 Milliarden
Euro aufstocken darin enthalten 50
Milliarden für die Ukraine und 16
Milliarden unter anderem für
Migration wir wissen wie schwierig es
ist die Mittel für die Ukraine zur
Verfügung zu stellen aber eins ist klar
wir müssen die Ukraine
unterstützen das will auch der deutsche
Finanzminister doch beim Streit um den
gesamten EU-Haushalt bleibt er har nicht
nur in Berlin sondern auch in Brüssel
seine Botschaft sparen hier muss klar
sein dass wir die Durchhaltefähigkeit
der Ukraine in diesem schrecklichen
Krieg mit allen unseren Möglichkeiten
weiter sicherstellen darüber hinaus
sehen wir allerdings wenig Notwendigkeit
und Möglichkeit zusätzliche Mittel für
etwa neue Vorhaben
bereitzustellen aber genau das wollen
einige Finanzminister sie wollen
zusätzliche Mittel für den Kampf gegen
illegale Migration und für die
Landwirtschaft nur Geld für die Ukraine
ist ihnen zu
wenig wir würden den Haushalt nicht
unterstützen wenn wichtige Programme für
unser Land gekürzt würden z.B
agrarprojekte die EU hat den
ukrainischen Präsidenten auf ihren
Gipfeln oft gefeiert der braucht nicht
nur Waffen sondern auch mehr Geld die
Überlebensfähigkeit hängt auch von den
50 Milliarden Euro ab n kommen Zweifel
auf die Kommission ist hier gefragt
endlich einen guten Kompromiss zu finden
sonst gibt es wirklich die Gefahr dass
die Ukraine hinten runterfällt davor hat
sie Angst olessia will uns noch ein Bild
aus besseren Tagen zeigen ihr Haus unter
dem Regenbogen ein Traum ohne die Hilfe
der EU wird er wohl nie
Wirklichkeit und bei uns geht's weiter
mit Heinz Wolf und den Nachrichten und
die beginnen mit dem Blick nach New York
zur UNO wo der unserheitsrat zur Stunde
erneut über den Krieg zwischen der Hamas
und Israel berät un-gensekretär guteres
hatte den Sicherheitsrat zu dieser
Dringlichkeitssitzung zusammengerufen
und gedrängt sich für einen humanitären
Waffenstillstand einzusetzen daraufhin
legten die Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate einen Resolutionsentwurf vor mit
der Forderung nach einem
Waffenstillstand jetzt gerade am Abend
haben die USA ihr Veto gegen den
Resolutionsentwurf eingelegt weil er der
wirklichen Lage nicht gerecht werde und
die Situation nicht
voranbringe in Dubai geht die
Weltklimakonferenz in die zweite und
entscheidende Woche ab heute führt
Außenministerin berbock die deutsche
Gruppe an und übernimmt für die EU die
Verhandlungsführung beim Themenkomplex
Emissionsminderungen sie pläerte für
einen weltweiten Ausstieg aus den
fossilen Energien außerdem forderte sie
wirtschaftsstarke Länder wie Saud
Arabien und China dazu auf in den
Finanztopf zur Abfederung von
Klimaschäden in ärmeren Ländern
einzuzahlen bundesinnenministerin fäer
will die Kontrollen an den Grenzen zu
Polen Tschechien und der Schweiz über
den 15 Dezember hinaus für mindestens
zwei Monate verlängern das sagte sie der
reinischen Post die Maßnahmen wirkten
der Kampf gegen das skrupellose Geschäft
der Schleuser sei erfolgreich so
fäer der Streik der
lockführergewerkschaft GDL hat zu
massiven Beeinträchtigungen im
Zugverkehr geführt rund 80% des
Fernverkehrs musste die Deutsche Bahn
einstellen auch im regional und
S-Bahnverkehr gab es zahlreiche
Verspätungen und Zugausfälle um 22 Uhr
beendeten die loogführer nach Angaben
der GDL ihren Streik die Bahn geht davon
aus morgen wieder zum regulären Fahrplan
zurückkehren zu können warnte aber dass
mit einer sehr hohen Auslastung der Züge
zu rechnen sei
Sätzen sech so muss man wohl das
Ergebnis der neuesten Pisastudie
zusammenfassen die Schulleistungen der
neunkläsler sind in den vergangenen
Jahren weiter abgestürzt in Mathe in den
Naturwissenschaften und auch beim Lesen
die Diagnose immer gleich es fließt zu
wenig Geld in Bildung und es gibt zu
wenig Lehrer und Lehrerinnen wobei
absurderweise niemand genau weiß wie
viele Lehrkräfte in den nächsten Jahren
eigentlich fehlen ging man vor kurzem
noch von einer lehrerlücke von 24 000
aus sind es nach neuen Schätzungen 70
bis über
100.000 ein Expertengremium das die
Kultusminister beauftragt hatten
empfiehlt nun die Ausbildung von Lehrern
zu verkürzen und gleichzeitig zu
verbessern Luisa huen berichtet aus
einer Realschule in
Baden-Württemberg der Stundenplan ein
Flickenteppich dieser Anblick ein
Millionen Schülerinnen und Schüler Lis
Unterricht an der Realschule deutenberg
beginnt an diesem Morgen erst zur
vierten Stunde die ersten drei fallen
aus mal wieder ohne Lehrer Ken
Vertretung und deswegen habe ich auch
erst jetzt 10:10 Uhr Schule letzte Woche
war es auch sehr schlimm da hatten wir
nur eine Stunde am einen Tag und es war
noch eine Vertretungsstunde heißt es war
unnötig weil wir da eh gezeichnet haben
unds selber beschäftigt haben in der
Schule dürfen wir nicht drehen viele
Orts wollen die Schulämter nicht dass
der Mangel sichtbar wird doch über
schulfrei können sich Lisa und viele
andere nicht mehr freuen so so eine
Angst weil das hat auch mit Meer Zukunft
zu tun wie mache ich das eigentlich wenn
wenn ich jetzt in der neunen bin w die
Prüfungen anstehen aber ich hat so so
viel Stoff bei mir fehlt wegen dem
ganzen Entfall die Sorgen der Schüler
ihre Lehrkräfte teilen sie längst hier
in Dresden und im ganzen Land nicht
zuletzt nach den miserablen
pisaergebnissen Schul daran sei auch der
enorme Personalmangel und viele die
durchhalten können nicht mehr Klasse mit
28 Kindern und diese Klasse führe ich
über 4er Jahre und ich bin stolz auf
meine Kinder aber manchmal auch am Ende
meiner Kraft die sozialen Probleme in
den Klassen werden immer höher die
schiefhalt in den Klassen ist größer
gerade in diesen schdeln die wo sozial
Gefühl geben sehr sehr schwierig ist
junge Menschen überlegen sich das
zweimal nachdem sie ein Praktikum an der
Schule gemacht haben ob sie diesen Job
überhaupt machen wollen weil sie auch
sehen wie das inzwischen geworden ist
und das ist einfach was da müssen wir
ran nur wie wenig geschult Aushilfen und
Quereinsteiger konnten die Lücken
bislang nicht füllen doch auf genau die
setzen nun bildungsexpertinnen und
Experten auf der Suche nach einer
dauerhaften Lösung wir müssen diejenigen
im System qualifizieren
nachqualifizieren die eben jetzt nicht
mit ausreichender Qualifikation als le
Lehrkräfte beschäftigt sind und das
insbesondere an Brennpunktschulen dafür
gibt es Ideen z.B ein neuer
Masterstudiengang speziell für
Quereinsteiger wie ihn besonders gern
gesehen W unter anderen
Mathematikerinnen und Physiker außerdem
soll das Referendariat verkürzt Studium
und Praxis besser verzahnt werden zum
einen darf auf gar keinen Fall der
Eindruck entstehen dass jeder Lehrer
werden kann dass wir frei von
Qualifikation jeden momentan in den
Schulen nehmen der bei dre nicht auf den
Bäumen ist und gleichzeitig müssen wir
aber die qualifizierten Akademiker von
denen ich gerade eben sprach im System
halten wie genau das gelingen soll will
die
Kultusministerkonferenz 2024
Lisa und viele ihrer Mitschüler setzen
währenddessen längst auf
Nachhilfestunden um Lücken im
Stundenplan wieder mit Wissen zu füllen
zumindest die die es sich leisten
können der sächsische Verfassungsschutz
hat die AFD im Freistaat als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft nach
Thüringen und SachsenAnhalt nun also der
dritte AFD Landesverband vier Jahre lang
hatte der Nachrichtendienst die
sächsische AFD beobachtet und fest
gestellt dass die Partei
verfassungsfeindliche Ziele verfolgt
gemeint sind damit rassistische
Positionen
verschwörungsideologisches Gedankengut
und die Nähe zu anderen rechtsextremen
Organisationen die AFD liegt in Umfragen
in Ostdeutschland auch in Sachsen im
Moment bei über 30% der Stimmen über
Reaktionen und folgen dieser Einstufung
berichten Thomas Bersch und Franziska
wunderlich es sind nicht unbedingt
Parteitage oder die Gespräche mit
Bürgern im Wahlkampf die den
Verfassungsschutz Sachsen auf den Plan
riefen und es ist schon gar nicht dass
sechische AFD Parteiprogramm dass das
Amt zu seinem deutlichen Fazit führte
das Parteiprogramm gehört mit zu der
Fassade die die Partei sich über Jahre
aufgebaut hat also man geriert sich als
grundgesetzkonform aber hinter der
Fassade verbirgt sich ein glasklarer
rechtsextremistischer Kern entscheidend
ist ja das was die i tagtäglich von sich
gibt und was da zusammenkommt hat das
Amt zusammengetragen und in sein Urteil
einfließen lassen insgesamt gehe es der
AFD darum das Vertrauen in die
Funktionsfähigkeit der Demokratie zu
erschüttern sie benutze dazu Begriffe
aus dem
verschwörungsmilieu und greife in der
Migrationsdebatte
völkischnationalistische Positionen auf
verwende kampfbegriffe wie umfolkung und
spreche pauschal von messermigranten
oder importierten Killern und all das
bleibe innerhalb der Partei weitgehend
ohne Widerspruch was wir eben vermisst
haben bisher sind kritische Stimmen sind
kritische Auseinandersetzung mit diesen
rechtsextremistischen Inhalten das ist
im grundeommen eine völlige Fehlanzeige
da werden sie so gut wie nichts finden
die Partei erscheint nach außen wie ein
monolitischer Block die AFD trat heute
den einzelnen Vorwürfen nicht konkret
entgegen und beließ es bei einem
Statement die Hochstufung war absehbar
weil die AFD derzeit stärkste Kraft in
den neuen Bundesländern ist trotzdem
entbrt die Hochstufung jeder sachlichen
Grundlage der Verfassungsschutz ist
schon längst zum regierungsschutz
motiert und dieser regierungsschutz
verfolgt für jeder Mann ersichtlich
einzig und allein wahltaktische Motive
damit schadet er der Demokratie dass es
die AFD so auslegen würde überrascht
Sachsens Innenminister kaum er stellt
klar es gehe nicht um
Wahlkampf wir lassen uns bei fachlich
juristisch
Beurteilungen Prüfungen
Entscheidungen nicht politisch leiten
sich zum mertürer zu machen das gehört
für ihn zum AFD Kerngeschäft die Frage
sei trotzdem wie das Votum des
Verfassungsschutzes beim wäher ankomme
das kann dazu führen dass einige
Wählerinnen und Wähler erst recht jetzt
die AFD im September nächsten Jahres bei
der sachsenwahl wählen aber es kann auch
dazu führen dass einige doch etwas
vorsichtiger sind und wenn sie in der
Wahlkabine stehen sich dreimal überlegen
ob sie einer rechtsextremistischen
Partei wirklich ihre Stimme geben ob und
wie sich also die heutige Einstufung der
AFD auf die Partei und auf ihre Wähler
in Sachsen auswirkt das wird sich erst
noch zeigen spätestens im nächsten
Herbst und bei uns geht's jetzt weiter
mit Heinz Wolf und Nachrichten aus der
Wirtschaft nach längeren Verhandlungen
gibt es auf EU-Ebene eine Verständigung
auf neue energievorgaben für Gebäude
Unterhändler des des Europaparlaments
und der EU-Staaten einigten sich auf
strengere Anforderungen an die
Energieeffizienz mit welchen Folgen für
den Energie Immobilienbereich Frank
betmann ja vor abstinger ja aber anders
als zunächst angedacht eine
Sanierungspflicht für Hausbesitzer wie
sie ursprünglich von der EU mal
angedacht war die ist vom Tisch sie war
bis zuletzt sehr kontrovers diskutiert
worden stattdessen werden nun die
Mitgliedstaaten in die Pflicht genommen
sie erhalten nationale einsparzi Ziele
die in zeitlichen Etappen erreicht
werden müssen bis 2035 sollen die
EU-Länder dann 20 bis 22% des
Primärenergieverbrauchs im
wohngebäudesektor einsparen
grundsätzlich sieht die Reform die
gebäuderichtlinie vor dass ab dem Jahr
2030 alle neuen Gebäude klimaneutral
sein sollen und ab 2050 der gesamte
Gebäude bestand in der EU wie die
einzelnen Länder das Erreichen ob sie
dafür z.B auch auf energieeffiziente
Fernwärmenetze setzen oder doch die
nationalen emissionsgesetze verschärfen
das steht Ihnen frei und noch kurz zum
DAX der heute schon wieder gestiegen ist
ja das deutsche Aktienbarometer
kletterte in der Spitze auf
16783 Punkte ein neues Rekordhoch
getrieben wird der seit Wochen
andauernde Aufwärtstrend von der
Hoffnung der Anleger die Notenbanken
könnten schon bald die Leitzinsen senken
dazu muss man wissen bei sinkenden
Zinsen werden Aktien gegenüber anderen
Anlagealternativen attraktiver Frank
betmann vielen Dank und zum Thema
Gebäudesanierung haben wir in unserem
hechenal Update später dann ein Gespräch
mit einer Expertin für
Gebäudetechnologie es gibt aktuelle
Unwetterwarnungen des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes gewarnt wird vor Glatteis
in Teilen von Bayern mehr zum Wetter
gleich von Christ
Orben das Internationale Olympische
Komitee erlaubt Sport innen und
Sportlern aus Russland und belaruss an
den Olympischen Sommerspielen 2024 in
Paris teilzunehmen unter neutraler
Flagge und unter Auflagen der
ukrainische Außenminister kritisierte
die Entscheidung scharf und erklärte
dass IOC habe Russland grünes Licht
gegeben Olympia als Waffe zu benutzen
Russlands Sportminister kritisierte die
Auflagen als
diskriminierend anders als bei ihren
letzten Olympia Auftritten sollen
Sportler aus Land und Belarus strickte
Neutralität waren außerdem muss nach den
Vorgaben des IOC nachgewiesen sein dass
die Teilnehmer den Krieg ihrer Länder
nicht aktiv unterstützen und den
antidopingcode einhalten
Militärangehörige sollen ebenso wenig
stberechtigt sein wie Mannschaften
beider Länder die Pariser
Bürgermeisterin ann idalg hatte sich
wiederholt gegen eine Teilnahme von
Sportlern aus Russland und belaruss
ausgesprochen deren Mitwirkung in Paris
im nächsten Jahr hat das IOC nun möglich
gemacht
das deutsche eiskunftlaufpaar mineva
Hase und Nikita volodin hat das Grand
Prix Finale in Peking gewonnen das
Berliner Duo Hase volodin trainiert erst
seit einem Jahr zusammen und feiert nun
den bislang größten gemeinsamen Erfolg
den letzten deutschen Sieg beim Grand
Prix Finale gab es 2017 für die späteren
Olympiasieger sevchenko und
Mass das war's von uns hier geht's jetzt
weiter mit der heutesow und um 0:20 Uhr
gibt's dann un unser heute schnall
Update mit Christopher wermann Ihnen
einen schönen Abend tschüss bis
[Musik]
morgen herzlich willkommen zum W ja
dieses Tief hier mit Schnee und Glatteis
das zieht morgen nach Osten hin ab aber
es folgt schon das nächste Tief und zwar
mit kräftigem Regen aus außerdem wird
dann der Weg frei für milde Luft aus
West und die sorgt dafür dass es jetzt
über das zweite Adventswochenende dem
Schnee an den Kragen geht das Tauwetter
verschont nur die höheren Lagen bis
Dienstag hier im Südosten und schon
heute Nacht bleibt es in der Westhälfte
frostfrei in der Osthälfte kommt diese
mildere Luft erst morgen an da sinken
die Werte noch mal auf -4° es schneit
anfangs auch noch weiter zwischen der
Ostsee und den Alpen in Teilen Bayerns
hercht weiterhin Glättegefahr durch
gefrierenden Regen bis in die
Frühstunden des Samst Stags erst am
Vormittag entspannt sich hier die
glätesituation insgesamt startet der
Samstag meistens trocken auch wenn es
oft stark bewölkt bleibt der Wind aus
Süd der frischt im Westen schon mal auf
und von hier zieht sie dann nachmittags
ein kräftiges Regenband bis in die Mitte
da können über 10 l regenfallen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen rheinlandfalz und
dem Saarland im Osten bleibt es bis zum
Abend trocken und hier kommen die
Temperaturen aus dem dauerfrostbereich
heraus + 2° gibt's in Vorpommern in der
Kölner Bucht da sind die Temperaturen
sogar im zweistelligen Bereich um 10°
und in den nächsten Tagen wird es sogar
noch wärmer und das in Kombination mit
weiteren starken Regenfällen lässt die
hochwassergefah in Süddeutschland Anfang
der neuen Woche steigen das war es von
uns ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen
Abend